[Music]
Nevada State Police stepping up
enforcement tonight after the big game
they're on the lookout for Dangerous
driving particularly for drunk drivers 8
news now getting the opportunity to take
a ride along one of their ghost vehicles
to catch these drivers in the ACT
Madison Kimbrough joins us live from nhp
Southern command headquarters with the
outcome hi Madison
yes it was a ride for sure as we tagged
along for about an hour and during our
ride with nhp Troopers we actually
stopped two drivers one of which was
arrested for DUI
some people they just you know they make
poor decisions so we're out there to
prevent any loss of life or a serious
injury hopefully just by us being out
there and starting this campaign it
could sway some people maybe they'll uh
take an Uber the Nevada State Police
Highway Patrol Division and other law
enforcement agencies coming together for
the month of February and what they call
their joining Forces campaign to ensure
safety on our roadways my missionary
night is to keep the roads safe from
speeding to driving while impaired nhp
is on the lookout for it all an impaired
driving doesn't just mean that alcohol
is involved nhp Trooper sharing that
it's anything that affects a person's
ability to safely operate a motor
vehicle so that includes phones and
music
Trooper Moran showing us firsthand just
how busy the roadways were after the
Super Bowl ended and in the midst of our
Drive pulled over two people
one of which was driving while under the
influence and eventually arrested and
according to nhp last year nearly 400
people died in crashes where impairment
and speed were the top two contributing
factors
and as for tonight's numbers nhp
confirming with me that as of 2 p.m
today there have been nine DUI arrests
two wrong way drivers and 12 crashes
reporting live Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now